fois dans le ministre j'aurais pu se
poser cette question à votre collègue
ministre des transports mais j'ai
considéré que c'était un réel problème
de l'aménagement du territoire c'est
pour cela que je vous la pose lors de la
restitution du grand débat monsieur le
président de la république a déclaré les
français en confiant à l'orée du locaux
et ce nouvel acte de décentralisation
doit porter sur des politiques de la vie
quotidienne dont le transport pour
garantir des décisions prises au plus
près du terrain
il avait bien compris que le détonateur
de la crise et gilet jaune avait été le
prix du carburant à l'occasion de la loi
de mobilité
elles tirent en règle s'est déclenchée
quand les petites lignes aériennes
intérieures à travers des amendements
demandant une nouvelle contribution au
décollage
la suppression de la quasi totalité des
lignes vous n'ignorez pas que ces
petites rides un rôle essentiel de
désagréments pour les territoires
éloignés
je pourrais citer ici aurillac le puits
biarritz clermont ferrand et d'autre
j'affirme que contrairement aux dires
des auteurs de ces amendements
céline ne sont pas emprunté par les
privilégiés vers majorité par des
acteurs essentiels de l'économie locale
madame la ministre
quelle est la position du gouvernement
sur ces attaques contre des terroristes
et toi enclavé et que proposez vous est
ce que le gouvernement est prêt à
s'engager à renoncer à toute taxation
supplémentaire ou interdiction qui
pénaliserait une fois de plus
l'aménagement du territoire pour vous
répondre la parole et au ministre de la
cohésion des territoires non et au
ministre d'état ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur de religion merci merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jeunesse je vois la joie qui
vous emplit me voir que c'est moi qui
réponds en effet c'est moi qui suis le
ministre de tutelle des transports et
elisabeth borne est retenu actuellement
par le débat sur la loi d'orientation
des mobilités à l'assemblée nationale je
croyais que votre question allait porter
sur les petites lignes ferroviaires mais
elle porte en réalité sur les petites
lignes entre guillemets aérienne en tout
cas sur les lignes en effet de
désenclavement
deux villes comme aurillac vous en avez
parlé on pourrait parler de castres de
différentes villes qui sont assez
éloigné de paris qui pour lesquels il
est difficile de se rendre en train avec
des temps de parcours qui soit
acceptable ou d'ailleurs aussi en
voiture et donc des lignes pour
lesquelles l'avion apporte un surcroît
de service alors tout d'abord je tiens à
dire que ce qui a été voté à l'assemblée
nationale ce n'est pas de surenchérir
le coût des billets d'avion c'est de
prélever un surplus non utilisés de la
taxe dite taxe chirac puisqu'elle avait
été créée sous la présidence de jacques
chirac pour financer vous le savez à
travers les billets d'avion des mesures
de solidarité internationale cela
représentera en l'occurrence 30 à 40
millions d'euros qui auront qui iront
financer l agence française des
infrastructures de transport vous le
savez aussi nous avons refusé
même si c'est une demande qui a été
beaucoup exprimée notamment parlé gilet
jaune et comme je sais que dans une
précédente question vous n'aviez pas
hésité à exprimer votre soutien à ce
mouvement je vous le rappelle c'est la
taxation du kérosène des avions sans
distinction nous nous avons pris une
position c'est de ne pas taxer le
kérosène des avions sur les vols
intérieurs sur les vols franco français
car nous savons qu'ils offrent qu'il y
aurait des effets de concurrence
déloyale avec nos voisins et d'avoir une
bataille au niveau européen et par
ailleurs je vous confirme que nous
continuions à subventionner car il ya
une subvention pour ses lignes et que
nous cherchons là aussi les meilleurs
opérateurs car parfois certaines
compagnies veulent se désengager donc
nous en trouverons d'autres pour
garantir cette desserte de tout le
territoire
monsieur jeunesse
merci monsieur le ministre mes
inquiétudes sur un peu levé mais pas
tout à fait pas d'autoroute pas de tgv
ni parfois de train et que si vous avez
la chance d'être ado trois heures d'une
gare tgv
celui ci est régulièrement en retard ou
et complet explosion du prix
d'électricité et vous le dit de prendre
des voitures électriques est maintenant
menaces sur les lignes intérieures
aérienne quel tableau pour la mobilité
dans ces territoires enclavés
je vous propose que le surplus de 30
millions d'euros de la taxe ne soit pas
transféré à l'as l'a fait aussi dire à
dire
voilà on s'est compris encore une agence
qui comme les autres coûtent très cher
en fonctionnement
je vous propose plusieurs choix tout
d'abord soir au soccer dans vos choix
reçoit d'affecter ses 30 millions à une
baisse de taxes sur les petites dean
soin de les affidés de soin de les
affecter à des travaux prioritaires dans
ces secteurs sur les routes ou peut-être
qu'un peu d'humour acheter des
trottinettes mais pas électrique parce
que l'électricité coûte trop cher ou
d'un compte twitter parce que la vidéo
vous n'avez pas retenu la leçon
arrêtez l'écologie punitive
rappelez-vous ce qu'a dit monsieur et
locker 2010